in 1997 former Saturday Night Live star
Mike Myers hit comedy goals with Austin
Powers international man of mystery
which was followed by hit sequels in
1999 and 2002 but despite the massive
popularity and box office success of the
franchise and the fact that everyone
involved wants to make another movie
we're still waiting for the next
installment and we may have to keep
waiting here's a look at why we never
got to see Austin Powers for development
hell the Austin Powers franchise
generated a ton of revenue for New Line
Cinema money which the studio invested
in films like The Lord of the Rings
trilogy but while that should have
ensured them footing for Austin Powers
for New Line Cinema got themselves in a
world of financial trouble with
expensive flops like the Golden Compass
and through public accounting disputes
with Lord of the Rings mastermind Peter
Jackson all of which led to New Line
Cinema pushing hard for Austin Powers
for in order to shore up their sinking
ship but before I could get made the
studio went under and was bought out by
Warner Brothers
no wonder development on Austin Powers
forestalled indefinitely Austin Powers 3
was in good the first - Austin Powers
movie saw the character moved from cult
phenom to blockbuster franchise star
spoofing James Bond while adding a slew
of new catchphrases to our vocabulary
$1,000,000 but despite being a financial
success the third film Austin Powers in
Goldmember didn't quite live up to the
reputation of its predecessors it opened
middling reviews thanks in part to an
over reliance on pop culture jokes of
the era which have not aged well at all
a Britney Spears cameo a Silence of the
Lambs
parody a scene with the Osborne with
gold member Austin Powers lost some of
his mojo meaning fans haven't exactly
been demanding a fourth film career
downturn between Austin Powers and Shrek
there was a time when Mike Myers
couldn't do anything wrong unfortunately
for him and his fans that time was more
than a decade ago since then it's been a
rocky road for Myers both professionally
and personally
in 2005 Myers and his wife Robin who he
described as his muse and who urged him
to write the first Austin Powers film to
begin with divorce and the one time star
suffered a string of box office and
critical bombs
including 2008 the Love Guru which at
the time of this video is still the last
major film role Myers is taken on
considering it's been nearly a decade
since Myers has made any movie the
chances of us and powers for happening
at this point seem very remote indeed
right okay people you have to tell me
these things all right I've been frozen
for 30 years okay throw me a frickin
bone here the animated hold up so how
cool would it be to see a TV series that
makes the best parts of both Shrek and
Austin Powers that might sound like a
pipe dream but it came very close to
happening after Myers cut a deal with
HBO for an animated awesome power series
featuring Myers is both the voice of
Austin Powers and dr. evil HBO
commissioned a 13-episode season which
was going to feature the kind of adult
themed content you'd expect to see on an
HBO cartoon Myers even handed it the
possibility of an animated prequel
origin film for Austin Powers as well
and then well nothing happened
HBO quietly canceled the series and
though neither the network nor Myers has
ever confirmed why writer Eric Goldman
has hinted that Myers backed out of the
project what we thought that was a good
idea even if Myers didn't dr. evil I
love your plan yeah yeah yeah it's a
really good plan it still could happen
despite all the holdups and dead ends
the franchise has suffered so far it's
possible that there will eventually be
an Austin Powers for for one simple
reason
Myers says he still wants to make it in
fact he's been pretty consistent on this
point telling the president 2007 2010
and 2016 that he was still working on
the film exactly what Austin Powers for
will look like when it finally arrives
is unknown so at one point Myer said the
next film will focus on dr. Evil's
relationship with the Sun Scott evil
don't look at me like I'm freaking
Frankenstein give your father a ha and
director Jay Roach who helmed the first
three film had said he also wants to be
involved which could make it a true
Austin Powers reunion you know Mike gave
me the break of a lifetime letting me
direct Austin
so I'm always good to go have any ideas
about what four would be like well Larry
probably something a lot like this
oh yeah baby
and also this get in my family and of
course lots and lots this welcome to my
new submarine lair its long and hard and
full of semen nothing no not even a
titter tough sub thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to